and horror
regarding its illustration of the day of
judgment and the day of resurrection.
In surah in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
to humanity
to the human being
one and all
[Silence]
He says,
"Subhan,
oh human being, indeed you are toiling
and working constantly
in and towards the meeting of your Lord
and indeed you shall certainly meet him.
So Allah tells us about every waking
moment we have here on this earth and
even unconscious moment. Every breath
that we take, every heart beat that our
hearts
have is a step towards the meeting of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And the irony
of it is that with each moment that
passes, we are closer at that moment
than we have ever been before to meeting
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This is the purpose of our lives.
The entire purpose of our life is
working towards that critical meeting
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then tells us
of the the split in the road, the fork
in the road, if you will, the proverbial
and sometimes physical fork in the road
that the human being will find himself
at the crossroads.
Hence upon that meeting, at that meeting
whoever is given his book of deeds in
his right hand, then he will be brought
to a light and brief judgment.
And then he will be allowed to be
reunited with his family in happiness
and bliss.
And at this meeting, whoever is given
his book in his left, whoever is given
his book behind his back,
then this person will call out in horror
and will be subjected
and entered into a blazing inferno.
If we are to take these verses here,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
there will be people who will be given
their books in their right hand and
people that will be given their books
behind their back.
Those who are given their books in their
right hand,
they will be brought to a brief, a
light, a general judgment. What does
that mean?
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam's bride
and wife and most beloved.
She tells us that once she heard the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam injur
making the dua.
Oh Allah,
judge me with a brief and gentle
judgment.
And
she asked him after he concluded his
prayer, "What is a brief and
light judgment? A generalized judgment?"
He said, he responded to her, "Anyone
who is brought to account on the day of
judgment for all and every one of his
deeds will go to hell.
There's no way around it."
She said, "But didn't Allah say,
as for those who are given their books
in their right hand, they will be judged
a light and general and brief judgment."
He said,
he said that is just a formality of
judgment.
Meaning the person will be brought forth
on the day of judgment. Generally they
will be
they will have their life discussed with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala generally not
every single thing.
As for those who are brought forth and
they are judged and brought to account
for every single deed, these individuals
are surely hellbound.
And so what is the brief and light
judgment? Iban Omar tells us that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said a man
will be brought forth on the day of
judgment and Allah will place his
barrier around him so that he is not
overheard by the judgment and the
dialogue is not overheard by anyone else
standing there.
And then Allah will say to this man, "Do
you remember on such and such day you
did such and such? Do you remember in
such and such year you did such and
such? Do you remember at such and such
place you did such and such?" And the
man will believe at that moment that he
is definitely going to hell because
Allah is only mentioning his bad deeds.
He says,
The man will continuously say, "Yes, I
remember. I acknowledge. I am guilty."
And so Allah will then say to him,
"I concealed these sins
while you were still in the dunya from
other people's eyes,
and I will forgive you for them today. I
forgive you." That is the easy judgment.
Did you guys hear? Does that sound like
an easy judgment?
Imagine yourself brought in front of
Allah and all he has to talk to you
about are your bad deeds and your sins.
You're naked. You're alone.
And you are filled with dark terror.
That is the easy judgment.
What in the world is the hard and harsh
judgment going to be like? That's
unimaginable. And that's why Allah
doesn't even mention harsh judgment in
the chapter.
He says, "And as for those who are given
their books of deeds behind their back,"
meaning in their left hand, but behind
their back, because people know where
they belong.
And when a person sees that the books
are being distributed,
people who are expecting to get their
deeds in their left hand, they will hide
their book their hand behind their backs
and then they will be given their book
of deeds behind their backs. this
scenario that I've just told you of.
This is the entire purpose of our lives.
That is what every one of us right now
is currently working towards. That's the
meeting we're going towards
and we can change and determine the
outcome of that meeting meeting right
now.
You you know sometimes people when they
read the Quran, they read narrations,
they get the wrong idea. They think that
you have to go to hell. There's no way
around it. You are not special. Only
super very special people will be saved
from hellfire. But me, no. Definitely I
have no chance. That could not be
further from the truth.
If Allah's mercy is not for those who
make mistakes, then who is it for?
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
tells us that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has designated a portion of mercy that
he will show humanity
in this life and the next he had divided
it into a 100 portions. one portion
he has used and made
a co-op
amongst all of the creatures in the
dunya from the dawn of humanity and life
on this earth until the day of judgment.
That's one portion. Even animals share
in that portion of one mercy. and 99
mercies it he has reserved only for
the believers on the day of judgment.
But you just have to try a little bit.
Every good deed you do is at least 10
times. But every sin
is never more than one time. And often
it can be forgiven. If you ask for
forgiveness, it can be forgiven. As a
matter of fact, it can be forgiven just
because
gates of paradise are eight. The gates
of the hellfire are seven.
The people
of paradise just from this ummah. The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said 70,000
men and women from this nation will
enter paradise without any judgment or
any punishment.
70,000. That's a lot. But being that
there's billions and billions and
billions of Muslim men, it's not so
many, right? So the prophet, your
prophet, he made dua to Allah
to increase him in those numbers. You
know what Allah did? He gave him with
every one of those 70,000
70,000 more.
Now your your chances go up.
Allah wants you to go to Jenna. He does
not want to punish you.
This is the worst of thoughts of Allah
that he must punish you. He's not
sadistic.
There is no value in your punishment if
you believe and work righteousness and
are repentant.
You just have to try a little bit and
the moment your death comes to you,
you're going to be hit with an
overwhelming feeling.
And we'll end with this inshallah. The
prophet Sam,
he says,
[Silence]
he said, "If a man from the day he was
born fell in prostration to Allah injur
and stayed in that position of
prostration, until he died of old age.
On the day of judgment, he's going to
belittle that deed. He's going to look
at it and feel I should have done
more.
And so
being that this is the case,
know that no matter how hard you work,
you can still do more and never feel
sufficed with what you've already done
because none of us can guarantee here
that Allah has even accepted anything
from any of us, let alone have
forgiven us. So we work hard but we
hope in Allah and we fear Allah's
judgment. This is the best of thoughts
in Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Having said that we will end with a dua
inshallah for our departed sister.
[Silence]
Allah
for
[Silence]
Allahbore. foric.
Having said that, inshallah we'll invite
our brother Hassan to see here to say
a few words inshallah. Then after that
we have food and and refreshments
there in the gym. So share
sister Natasha's mother
[Arabic recitation]
Natasha her mother has passed away.
There's a microphone for you here
be okay has passed away as well. We
ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to forgive
her sins and raise her levels in
paradise and that he write her book of
deeds in and that he unite her with
the best of mankind on the other side of
death.
Amen.
Alhamdulillah.
, just a quick brief before I start
the dua. , I call her, you guys call
her. I call her Amiji because
can you hear me now? Okay. , most of
you know brother Makud's mother, brother
Khalid's mother and as as brother
Shabbah's mother as as Mktarum. I call
her Amigi. So this is something I was
dear and dear close to her and I know if
she was present amongst us, she would
not understand a lick of English. So
with that being said, the dua would be
in Udu. Ask your neighbor next door to
translate it for you.
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Okay. food there in the gym.
Everybody can head over that way.
please one thing to mention,
do not leave your children in this room
unattended
because they will break things. we
have this kind of a constant problem. So
please take your children with you so
they can eat. Thank you. Upstairs too,
same thing. Don't leave them unattended,
please.